this point, teams doing search and rescue work, Yes,
it makes the building, one more building is destroyed
yes, search and rescue teams on the side of it,
search and rescue
teams are also moving away from that point now, it was
demolished backwards, the building
collapsed backwards, at the moment, the teams are at this point, the teams are
warned at this point  they are doing it,
the building was evacuated to remove the citizens, the
latest information was in this direction, now
YouTube is
here, the
citizens waiting in the building to warm up also took to the streets again, the
citizens waiting for their relatives here now
had to remove them, the teams are
now in a risky area where we are now Because a few buildings are
bigger  they make sure they don't fall
teams
[Music]
are evacuating the area right now that new building